i'm on my way
hello there my name is lucy and it has
been a while hasn't it
welcome to today's episode of the
outriders broadcast after a long
development it has been so awesome
seeing people jump into the game and see
what makes outriders blend of intense
action and deep rpg so special and we
really hope you've enjoyed your time on
enoch so far
but let's not beat around the bush here
we pride ourselves on transparency and
putting the player first and it really
was heartbreaking that there were
technical issues and game balance issues
at launch
and the team have been working
tirelessly to regularly improve fix and
update the game to deliver the
experience that you guys deserve
and today
we're here to put things right this show
is all about the future of outriders and
there's lots of very juicy stuff to get
into but first let's take a look at the
new huge free update that is coming to
outriders
we hope this will act as a nice little
reset moment for those of you who have
wanted to check out the game or those of
you who have had some issues along the
way
today we present a new horizon for
outriders
jacob you still got tunes
dudes let that be dropped
[Music]
let there be guitars
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
oh
i've heard such terrible terrible things
about you
how many of my people did you kill
just to reach it
[Music]
how about that then there's not much
more to say when it comes to world
slayer other than it's a fully formed
expansion to the game that takes the
outriders to the furthest reaches of
enoch in an all-new story that poses
their biggest challenge to dates
there's loads more to talk about when it
comes to world slayer but that i'm
afraid is a topic for another day
so you've just had a very whistle-stop
tour of what is coming to the game
but we've still got a little bit of time
together haven't we so i'm gonna pass
the mic over to the fountain of all
knowledge sven and he's gonna give you a
much deeper dive of the update and
specifically how it shakes up the
outrider's end game for the better
here's your new horizon spotlight
[Music]
hello everyone sven here to give you the
full lowdown on what exactly this
massive new update brings to the table
as we have always said outriders is not
a live service game although we have
constantly updated and improved the
player experience and focused our
attentions on the core game to ensure
players receive the game they deserved
and we intended
this continued focus has allowed us to
improve our drivers in a growing number
of ways and in our commitment we have
gone to town now a few short months
later we'd like to lift a hood on how we
improved our riders and show you exactly
what we've been working on okay let's
take it from the top
when outriders originally launched the
endgame experience players were having
sadly didn't quite align with what you
wanted and what we expected
this was arguably our greatest challenge
to resolve
rewards for expeditions were granted
based on how quickly you could complete
an expedition for most players this
meant forcing themselves into a specific
playstyle based on damage per second
only
[Music]
this stifled build diversity
and the tremendous creativity our
players bring to the table
expeditions now have no timer by default
in this new system finishing an
expedition regardless of how long it
takes will earn you that expedition's
reward rewards have also been equalized
so that even expeditions that
fundamentally take longer to finish
will still be respectful of your time as
a player and will feel rewarding to
complete
this means that you won't need to sprint
to the end of an expedition in order to
get the best possible loot
you can take as long as you want and
play an experiment with the character
build of your choosing all without being
punished you can still run a timed
expedition if you prefer but this would
be only for bragging rights not for
improved rewards
at launch grinding for legendary gear
wasn't fun and didn't feel rewarding
enough even when playing on the highest
difficulty levels it was also very hard
to find specific items due to the random
nature of the system
since then we've implemented a hundred
percent increase to all legendary drop
rates globally we also developed an
anti-duplication system which reduces
the likelihood of players getting items
they already own
furthermore another change made to
expeditions that will benefit legendary
dude hunters is the final mission the
eye of the storm will now grant you a
pick and choose legendary item reward
upon completion you'll be able to choose
one of three gear pieces with your
options being randomly pulled directly
from the full loot pool
finally we've also made tiago more
useful
thiago's shop now offers options for a
mystery legendary purchase and you can
spend drop pod resources to reroll this
elite offer
getting all the legendary gear in the
game is all well and good but what if
you want to look a certain way but your
build relies on mods or set photos that
is only available on a certain piece of
gear it's one of the most requested
features from you so far
we've added transmogrification
which will let you change the visual
aspect of an item to that of another
item of the same type for weapons it
also includes all sounds pretty cool huh
transmogging is entirely free no
convoluted systems microtransactions or
in-game resources required and there's
no limit to how often an item can be
transmogrified as soon as you've
acquired an item you will also acquire
its transmog design
your transmog library spans across your
entire account
meaning it collects designs from all
your characters in your roster into one
pool let's check out a few examples say
you really love the look of your
devastate legendary gear set but you
just wished your badass trickster could
wear it while maintaining your perfect
tricks to build
with just a few clicks in a visual
customizer your wish can now become a
reality after changing the look from the
trespasser set to the marshall set your
tricks to build with all its abilities
is still the same but now you're
sporting a mean devastator look
anomaly apogee is an effing awesome
shotgun but sometimes it's one of those
days where you just don't feel like
carrying around a bulky animal skull
feather thing
instead you prefer your gun to look like
one of the newly introduced weapons from
the new horizon update
given you already found a rooney scythe
you just need to apply the design onto
your effigy and you're good to go
don't forget it's inside what counts
underneath the new look is all the
functions of the anomaly effigy power
and perks included
transmog truly lets you express your
style whilst keeping that perfect build
that has been tuned to perfection for
the most vicious of endgame expeditions
if you want to run into the eye of the
storm with rusted gear
do it
if you missed that first legendary gun
you sport it bring it back
if you have the hell rangers back and
want your pyro to look like a badass
biker well you know the drill by now
head to the visual customizer and raise
some hell
we also don't want you to lose track of
what items you already transmarked in
your inventory that's why customized
gear will be marked by this new
symbol another important note you do not
have to dismantle any gear to acquire
the design for it as soon as it pops up
in your inventory it'll be part of your
transmog collection can you fill and
complete your transmog library
to get you started and in celebration of
the new horizon update release we have
another little cool sum fit for you
everyone locking on this week and that
means new and existing players will
receive a unique legendary armor piece
awesome changes but feel like you've
already completed everything there is to
do not riders
ah a new expedition would be nice you
say we hear you how about four and how
about for free
we added four brand new and massive
expeditions taking you to previously
unexplored areas of enoch each featuring
an exciting mini story connecting you
with characters and events experienced
in the main campaign
molten depths will send you back to
eagle peaks when a drop pod signal
activated dunham investigated and found
a hidden power station
in order to take it back online she
wants you to clear out the station from
any unwanted tenants no matter the size
shape and form
the city of nomads will confront you
with a character who is haunted by the
sins of his past very aware of his dark
history you decide to help him in
protecting the old pax village oketu
atara
[Music]
in the marshalls complex corrigan the
great grand marshal himself asked you to
reclaim a facility near deadrock pass
taken by insurgents
it won't take you long to discover that
this facility is anything but just
another insurgent camp
last but not least the wellspring
thiago told you about a pax legend of a
sacred place called atumaitaru where
pilgrims would take long travels to
sacrifice their treasures into deep
wells
you and your team are in search of those
forgotten riches if it wasn't for this
tremendous storm that seems to get
stronger and stronger
even new expedition players will already
have access to the first of the four
fresh expeditions with the others
unlocking a challenge tier 4 8 and 12
and without a timer requirement to get
the gear feel free to take your time and
explore
that's something you should definitely
keep in mind when visiting these four
new locations cause they're a bit
different and special in many ways
but wait there's more here's a very fast
recap of the many changes our drivers
has undergone since launch and that you
can look forward to when returning to
enoch as part of the new horizon update
yeah i know you'd just love to hum along
to the tune of the opening video but we
reckon you've probably seen the intro
one too many times now check it out with
the new horizon update you're able to
skip it and get into the game much
quicker now hey you're welcome
for console players we've added a number
of new control settings and
customization options
a core focus for us is to enable players
to experiment with build diversity and
play outriders in a way that is the most
fun to you
using this is our guiding philosophy we
focused on buffing players gear and
skills for all four classes if you stop
playing shortly after launch and are
only getting back into the game now you
will feel tankier and will deal more
damage
maybe take some of your previously
neglected skills out for a spin too
trust me it'll be worth it
here's how we improve the multiplayer
experience we now have fully functioning
cross-play across all platforms
including stadia matchmaking rules have
been improved to enable players to find
better connections that have less lag
rubber banding or disconnections we also
implemented a matchmaking rule to check
for afk players to help you find active
partners and get into the game quicker a
kick protection from expeditions has
been implemented you can no longer be
booted from a session before claiming
your expedition reward and i mean what
kind of jerk would do something like
that anyway we also greatly reduced
multiplayer crashes and disconnection
issues leading to an overall much more
stable experience
and i think that's actually about it for
now
if you're after more detail be sure to
drop by the outrider social channels
over the next couple days where we will
be deep diving on the finer points of
all these great changes we hope you are
as excited as we are for the new horizon
update and we can't wait to share more
about the exciting future ahead thank
you again for your relentless support
and please stay healthy out there
and with that back to you lucy
the new horizon update brings a host of
new content and improvements to the game
offering up a perfect moment to jump
back into outriders or perhaps start
your journey across enoch for the first
time
and the best news of all
the new horizon updates will be
available and live across all platforms
as of this week however we are going to
round out the show as we always do with
a community q and a fielding your
questions so where's my boy
robbie hey everyone welcome back to your
outrageous community q a i'm your host
community manager robbie palmer and
without further ado
let's just jump into these spicy
delicious off-world questions
when will the new horizon update be live
new horizon will be live across all
platforms on november 16th so you won't
have to wait long to play our four new
expedition maps or fabulously transmog
your characters
stay tuned to our social channels for a
time zone breakdown of when the patch
goes live in your region and on your
platform
how much does the new horizon update
cost
new horizons is going to cost you
absolutely nothing
nada
nilch aka is completely free as long as
you own the base game
what else have we changed since the
launch of outriders
since the launch of outriders we've had
a dedicated team focusing on ensuring
that the in-game issues are addressed
and the overall experience is improved
on top of these and numerous other
quality of life improvements we've
worked hard on resolving crashes and
fixing bugs including the infamous
inventory wipe
if you're affected by this at any stage
you'll be happy to hear that your
inventory has been restored and that
everything is waiting for you to jump
back into the game
on top of the new expedition maps the no
timer expedition mode and the transmog
system that introduced in the new
horizon update there are plenty of
changes that have gone into the game
over time through our regular
so even if you checked in with app
writers in between launch and today
there's sure to be new stuff waiting for
you to try out
if you haven't yet logged in to acquire
your player appreciation package you
will also find this waiting for you
it features a legendary weapon a newer
moat and extra titanium based on your
character's level
just check in your main character's
inventory
speaking of freebies to celebrate the
new horizon update we're placing another
celebration package in everyone's
inventory you can look forward to a free
legendary armor piece when you next log
in
it will be an armor piece that you
haven't previously received and don't
worry the cannonball sets will not be
granted
and yes
everyone will get this celebration
package
but don't delay because this celebration
package is only here for a short time
and must be redeemed soon
when can i get more information on
worldslayer
we are desperate to share more
information on worldslayer but we want
to ensure that it will be absolutely
ready to be seen when we first show it
stay tuned to our social channels for
more world slayer updates in the coming
months
finally to celebrate the release of the
new horizon update and the announce of
world slayer we are giving away a number
of nvidia rtx 3080 gpu cards via our
twitter and discord social channels be
sure to drop by to find out how you can
enter the sweepstakes
and that is a wrap on the community q a
if you have any other burning questions
that need answering be sure to follow us
on twitter and send it our way
a big thank you to everyone for your
support since launch we are excited to
bring you the new horizon update and
share more information on world slayer
with you very soon
back to you lucy
listen we know it's been a trying time
since the launch of outriders but
hopefully today has shown you our
dedication to the game and its players
as well as laying down what's to come in
the near future
world slayer is gonna blow your head off
and we can't wait to share more with you
in the near future
until then
goodbye
[Music]
so
[Music]
you